[Musique]
quartier indien de paris métro la
chapelle ici une rue entière la rue
louis blanc est dédié au sri lankais on
peut prier s'habiller manger comme au
pays
[Musique]
mind and est d'origine tamoule une
ethnie minoritaire et persécutés du sri
lanka il est arrivé en france à l'âge de
sept ans après avoir fui son pays avec
sa famille aujourd'hui petite balade
dans le quartier et déjeuner
traditionnel
son est bon qu'ils ne travaillent pas
ils viennent ici ils font des rencontres
et par la pride a fait tous les produits
sont
les tamouls sont 90 milles à gouffran
france c'est la troisième diaspora
tamoule dans le monde et s'ils sont si
nombreux c'est parce que dans leur pays
trente ans de guerres civiles des oppose
aux cinghalais l'ethnie au pouvoir au
sri lanka depuis le départ du colon
britannique un conflit dont on retrouve
des traces jusque sur les murs de paris
lui c'est l'un des 22 personnes qui se
sont immolés l'année dernière par
rapport à la cause tamoule en fait pour
que l'opinion internationale se focalise
par rapport à la jeunesse comme ils
s'appellent moto comme
une méthode extrême pour être entendu
mais heureusement ce n'est pas la seule
cet après midi mind and se joint un
cortège tamouls pour une manifestation
nous sommes dans la cour du louvre en
plein coeur de paris lui emblème des
tigres tamouls vient se mêler au drapeau
tricolore
depuis la nuit des temps depuis donc des
millénaires
le tigre c'est l'animal sacré donc pour
les tamouls après pas des états à
mettre d'accord donc après donc les
tigres tamouls du libérateur dans les
années 80 lorsqu'il a commencé à
à mener la lutte armée ils ont repris
donc le tigre comme symbole est
également ils ont rajouté donc les
larmes les armes pour revendiquer donc
leur point de vue par rapport à la lutte
les tigres tamouls la branche armée
indépendantiste est considéré par la
communauté internationale comme une
organisation terroriste pour les jeunes
ici le peuple tamoul est trop souvent
assimilée aux tigres et ce regard doit
changer mind and place l'histoire dans
la jeunesse exilé bébé fait que les
jeunes qui naissent en france ou qui
sont arrivés de france et qu'ils
étudiaient etc france puisse contribuer
donc assez à ce qu'on fait là donc de
par leur connaissance par rapport à
octobre et la connaissance la mémoire
chez les tamouls elle se transmet par la
famille le dimanche après midi chez mind
and les femmes se retrouvent avec les
enfants aujourd'hui son père garagiste
est en plein travail mon père il avait
un commerce aussi là-bas au sri lanka il
a été arrêté puis il a eu des
souffrances il a été violenté sa mère
dans ma grand mère elle a pris la
décision que quittent le pays donc c'est
comme ça que la diffusion le pays et
puis il est venu en france l'année
dernière le gouvernement sri lankais a
lancé ce qu'il appelle la guerre finale
contre les indépendantistes
quarante mille civils tamouls auraient
été tués dans les combats et des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
parquées dans des camps dans les
offensives mind and a perdu son oncle et
ses deux cousins ils ont joué avec moi
quand j'étais petit au sri lanka quand
j'avais six sept ans donc avant que je
vienne
en france on était tous là en train de
jouer tout ça beaucoup moi c'est ces
moments là qui sont encore moins et
après pâques on
quand on nous apprend que ces êtres là
sont plus
sur la terre
cela fait six ans qu'il n'est pas rentré
au pays un pied ici un pied là-bas comme
il dit mais pas question de perdre
totalement sa culture ou sa religion
même si en france on fait quelques
aménagements savoir que pour les tamouls
vierge marie donc qui à lourdes 1 c'est
très important pour nous parce que
presque tous les ans tous les tamouls
prés même s'ils sont pas de
religion catholique ils se rendent là
bas ils croivent à la vierge marie y
croivent qui est va apporter quelque
chose pour les tamouls en fait
rendez-vous ensuite avec mind and au
spectacle annuel de danse traditionnelle
tamouls à montreuil 48 écoles sont
représentés 400 jeunes filles qui monte
sur scène des petites françaises
d'origine sri lankaise tout imprégnés de
leur culture
flamand
mais la politique n'est jamais bien loin
derrière les strass et les paillettes la
diaspora s'activent la jeunesse s'engage
elle vient même d'organiser en france un
référendum sur la création d'un
territoire tamoul indépendant
le terminal sera de nouveau créé
écoutons plutôt bourgeois y livre très
librement et avec des moyens
quand il a besoin pour survivre
était de toute façon elle a plus
aujourd'hui politique mais la lutte
continue
de manière ferme et n'être plus de
trente ans de guerres civiles n'ont pas
permis de résoudre le problème du sri
lanka
aujourd'hui c'est sur la communauté
internationale et sur eux-mêmes que mind
and ses amis compte